[Music]
all right so on Monday House Majority
Whip Steve Scalise took to Twitter to
defend President Trump and congressman
Scalise wrote President Donald Trump
went into this meeting with Putin from a
position of American strength to combat
Russian aggression but it's important to
remember how Russia was allowed to get
to this point anything gave a timeline
of all the Obama administration failures
with Russia starting with the reset he
joins us now the House Majority Whip
Louisiana Congressman Steve Scalise why
don't you just go through this because
this is I didn't want to put it in my
hand at a history lesson because I
thought you did a good job but I did
show Hillary with that silly reset
button of hers and don't forget the
cackle Sean great to be back with you
look there were so many different things
that Barack Obama did when he was
president you know he mocked Mitt Romney
in that 2012 debate saying you know the
80s want their foreign policy back when
Romney said Russia's a big threat the
red line was probably one of those
glaring points where he truly did go
backward in terms of strength when he
literally put that red line and said
Syria you know you've got to do these
things don't gas her own people and of
course after Syria gassed their own
people he just sat back and let it go
when the Ukraine I mean you're talking
about good friends of ours allies of
America we're being invaded President
Obama set by and did nothing in the
Ukrainians by the way we're asking the
Obama administration not for boots on
the ground but just for weapons to
defend themselves and he turned his back
on him President Trump by the way in
contrast
gave the Ukrainians missiles gave them
the ability to stand up to Russia
President Trump has stood up to Russia
on a number of fronts obviously that was
one expelling diplomats President Trump
increased sanctions he worked with us in
Congress to increase sanctions against
Russia so there's a big contrast between
Obama's threat many times
yeah Russia did it yeah they metal yeah
they interfered it's sort of like the
left if you're not backing up the Brinks
truck and trying to bribe some type of
despot or dictator if you're not making
meaningless lines in the sand that you'd
never have any intention of backing up
if you show weakness and it you appease
they like that
keep in mind Shawn I'm keep in mind the
meddling the actual meddling in the
election happened under President
Obama's watch Ashley he was president
there's evidence that he knew some of us
was right and he just didn't do anything
because he thought Hillary was gonna win
so you look at what President Trump has
done he's acknowledged there was
meddling we by the way and chairman
Nunez and his committee have done a
great job you've pointed out but Devin
Nunez and his committee showed there was
meddling but there was no collusion
between either campaign and the meddling
didn't have anything to do to change the
outcome of the election we should still
pursue it and we are but the the
meddling itself actually happened under
Barack Obama's watch all right
congressman glad we have a few strong
Republicans there that are willing to
actually tell truth and give a proper
history thank you for being one of them